the runs of the storm on Saturday was
hitting Upstate New York and the great
lakes with snowfall and high winds many
now stranded in their homes for
Christmas I uh live in what you might
call the stereotypical American suburbs
uh if you could picture that and I
cannot walk to the sidewalk uh in front
of my house about 20 meters from my
front door thousands and thousands and
thousands of people here in just in
Western New York State have lost power
for a period of hours and uh they're
just coping with extra blankets and lots
of Christmas sweaters
despite an official ban on driving in
some areas there were fears that many
had ventured out anyway thinking that
the worst was over only to get stranded
this may turn out to be the worst storm
in our community's history there are
still likely hundreds of people still
stuck in vehicles uh including
individuals who tried to drive out in
the late night hours last night but this
is the festive season in the U.S one of
the busiest travel periods of the year
and even though thousands of flight
delays and cancellations were reported
some passengers were determined to
complete their holiday travel our whole
airport shut down so we drove to Omaha
Nebraska
got on a flight there
then then DC delayed in DC
and now we're here
even though winter storm Elliott has
moved way to the north it's aftermath of
freezing temperatures mean cities from
Pennsylvania to Florida are being told
to expect the coldest Christmas on
record although climate scientists say
it's difficult to ascribe a single
weather event to climate change what we
are seeing is in keeping with the models
they've been warning about for years a
warming Arctic disrupting the jet stream
and plunging polar air southwards more
and more frequently and just in general
an increase in a variety of extreme
weather events
she had her tendency Al Jazeera
Washington